[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
so i got my car today this morning at
eight in the morning and philadelphia
freedom was on by helping john
and i started singing it and my wife is
looking like when the [ __ ] did you learn
these lyrics i go dog oh this is sixth
grade on fridays mr levito will let me
go up in front of the class at one
o'clock and i would sing philadelphia
freedom and lip-sync it
and my eyes are georgia by frankie
valley and [ __ ] makes you take
[ __ ] deep
with uh with
with the
[ __ ] the elton john people don't
remember elton john
every once in a while i get caught up
and john i can't even go in the house
country comfort comfrey uh a funeral for
a friend last week something was on
daniel my friend
and i and there's two gay guys live
across the street from me but they're
the [ __ ] weirdest gay guys because
they don't go out they don't do nothing
they sit in that [ __ ] house all day i
want to kick that door down and go you
know anybody tell your [ __ ] gay get
out there
dick is free
sperm is free you go to santa monica you
know what dick is free free these two
gay guys stay in the [ __ ] and they're
not gay together what they're not
together
they're roommates yeah they're roommates
and they never [ __ ] go out
every once in a while in the daytime
they take a cruise they're in front of
the house feeding cats
so when the other dad got out of the car
i was listening to elton john and i was
blasting i was stoned
you know when the weed and the music
just connected as one i pulled up to the
house and they were like out there and i
opened up the window and i go nobody in
this country remembers when elton john
used to sling dick like a [ __ ]
and they just looked at me looked at
each other within the house
what is a [ __ ] pipe holy [ __ ]
somebody gave me that cleavage that's
the savage stuff
we only let him out for special
occasions he's amazing oh my god do the
people at home see this thing oh that
thing is [ __ ] tremendous i've jerked
off everywhere
i have found a way like this time you're
sitting there like you know what i got
10 minutes
right you never walked off when you're
in the trailer for your factory oh i
walked off [ __ ] yeah you just you never
wiped off when you were editing in an
office no why not you're by yourself you
ever whack off driving [ __ ] yeah i've
not not fully but i've like gotten
horned out but i've never i can't
imagine coming on like oh i [ __ ] want
have you really yeah [ __ ] yeah you look
for an old mcdonald's bag you wipe that
[ __ ] sperm on it i get nervous when i
sneeze when i'm driving in the back seat
how are you
green in three [ __ ] days i only
walked off once while driving and i i
remember after i jerked off while i was
driving i was like great now i jerk off
in the car too i was thinking i was
gonna do this all the time and i for
whatever reason i only did it once one
[ __ ] i think i did it one time it was
when i was driving limos i just lifted
up my shirt shot one all over my stomach
put the shirt down patted it
down about my merry way
coming back from new hampshire i was
talking to somebody today who had to get
uh
fertility testing and i'm surprised more
people don't miss like the cup like just
get into it and forget about the cup
it was really weird he was telling me
they had like an eye like an apple tv
full of porn like in mostly a lot of
transvestite stuff
he said a lot of transgender stuff
a lot of transvestite stuff how would he
know how much transvestite stuff they
had he looked blue let's see what we got
here
well this one's not doing it for me he
said there wasn't a lot of girl and girl
that's what he was surprised about he
said it was mostly regular like big
boobs or gay and transvestite
big boobs or gay and transvestite wow
i wonder what their business where was
this where part in l.a i don't know
where he went uh but it was i almost got
tricked tonight by a uh transgender
person i was in subway before because i
know this edible's gonna kill me
this man i guess came in but i couldn't
tell from behind had the best ass i've
probably ever seen on anything but then
i actually used a t-shirt white jeans
and a jacket i didn't see the shirt no
one ever put blonde hair yeah i saw her
walking up and down yeah she's a hooker
she she has a but i heard her in her
voice i was like oh that's not a girl
and then she turned around i was like oh
that's really not a girl
but i i can't like i got tricked like
have you ever been no you got tricked if
you suck this dick that's how you got
tricked
you didn't get tricked but you just saw
and said let me get my [ __ ] together
before she hypnotizes me you know slave
labor people don't give a [ __ ] when it
comes to apple
they just don't give a [ __ ]
they really don't give a [ __ ] who killed
who died
you know people stopped giving diamonds
because somebody suffered
tons of people suffer with those [ __ ]
iphones nobody gives a [ __ ]
every time i walk to a different city
and i walk in that mall
and that apple store it's pack jack
at whatever time you walk past the
[ __ ] mall today that apple store
they're they're [ __ ] just that those
registers are ringing yeah how i i
haven't heard of somebody going into an
apple store with 20 guns
like kim kardashian style is behind me
beside me
if i was 22 today like as crazy as i was
i'd be taking down those apple stores i
don't think anyone uses cash you don't
need the cash i'd take all that [ __ ]
merch within eight minutes i'd get it
down to the guys i can eat
to get down to a [ __ ] a stopwatch
everybody down nobody wants to get hurt
i don't want to shoot nobody's [ __ ]
latte you know what i'm saying
i don't want to shoot nobody's kale
salad everybody down
you take their iphones you take all the
iphones and stuff somebody should be
doing this [ __ ]
nobody's doing this [ __ ] everybody
scared the pieces and then when i was 21
i said [ __ ] new york
people are looking for me i got to get
out of town so i came out here and i
tried to make give this a go you know
and he wasn't going for a journal he was
like you got a room upstairs you got a
week to get your [ __ ] together if you
don't get it together no where you got
to go dawg and i was like you're my
mother's brother but he threw me out and
i couldn't take it so i tried to rob him
[Laughter]
i couldn't go home with nothing so i
pulled guns when he pulled guns the cops
came the cab came
because i was robbing him as he pulled
up and he called the cops and the cab
came
so i swore to god i go next time i see
i'm gonna [ __ ] shoot you you
[ __ ] i mean this was terrible
this was horrendous didn't you call him
from prison was it him i used to call
him from prison
had him on the podcast
do you say it's the drugs i'll tell you
when you do that many drugs and you wake
up the next morning the next day you're
very unconscious
the best days i had as a salesman when
nights i [ __ ] i felt my spine
tingling
you know
when nights that i [ __ ] felt the
electric jolt of cocaine i would be a
sports salesman and i would wake up and
go in there and by 12 o'clock i'd make
three grand is it like a hangover or
what is it like it wasn't it was a
hangover but i'm unconscious i really
don't know what i'm doing
you know when you think about things and
you go into something
and you think about it you can't really
it's when you don't think about it it's
when you're just flowing and i would
just flowing the guy would say joey no
nerves what is it on saturdays you
always do great and i remember i used to
smudge so much coat then that i couldn't
even get sprays to open up my nose so i
would take two tissues and just stick
them up my nose so the drain and i would
sit there all day with two tissues they
would look at me and go what's up
nothing
at the car dealership no no no sports
deals oh sports betting you know i
called pete i go pete you money because
no no take the week i took the thursday
friday and saturday so i get to do the
thursday night
he's not there the wife is there
so the same thing [ __ ] happened right
before i go on stage and at that time i
wasn't my head wasn't in it like that
she came up to me she's like listen
i heard rumors not here here we work
spotless clean
if you say one bad thing you're fired
oh those [ __ ] people well guess what
i [ __ ] my pants
i really didn't for the first 15 i tried
i struggled i was eating
death and then i just let loose and they
went [ __ ] bananas i said [ __ ] it i'll
just take the 200 for the night i don't
give a [ __ ]
i walked off she didn't talk to me
the next night i came in the husband was
there i pulled him aside like she didn't
[ __ ] know she goes i explained to her
last night what happened i'm sorry danny
that was his name
i'm sorry
i go up there
and right there it was one of those
clubs or right here is the stage and
people actually take their drinks and
they're looking at me like this
and 20 minutes into my [ __ ] show i'm
looking at this couple and i'm looking
at her and she's [ __ ] up generally
and i'm like oh jesus christ
and finally i keep checking out like
every eight minutes and she's getting
deeper and deeper she's closing one eye
once they close the one eye
they're [ __ ] up
and finally i go stronger like this
and she covers her log
no no no no the puke starts shooting not
everybody sad boys
like a [ __ ] what's that thing the
kids playing like a like a sprinkler but
just awkward chunks and then she just
let it all out and she sat there for
five minutes puking all over herself bro
nobody paid everybody got up like
somebody was shooting you thought
terrorists were shooting at the club
everybody got up and started running for
the [ __ ] door they had to stop people
she had a puddle of barf around the
boyfriend left
the boyfriend just got up and walked out
he didn't know nothing
you didn't see me with me give me back
my credit card
i never went back there again once
somebody pukes on stage i can't i can't
hang out with you no more when i was
going at uh uh kettlebell gym like
really like the [ __ ] deadlifts and
[ __ ]
i had dick for days like i could jerk
off give somebody a stabbing and i too
have to bang one out again standing up
that's the worst you gotta bang one out
standing up in your bathroom hiding
against the doors
yeah there's something pathetic about
jerking off standing up i haven't done
that alone oh that's a disgusting way
when you have to bang one out in the
shower and then you're late i like
hotels because you lay down
on your back and it just comes on you're
like a fountain you don't give a [ __ ] at
your own time my married friend since he
has to do it into the toilet like he
does it on his iphone in his bathroom
because his girlfriend oh my god he
should be shot
and it's brutal you do comedy at a ping
pong table
did you want a poughkeepsie i did the
one in poughkeepsie i did that one a
couple times that's in a ballroom way
yeah and the next it's next to a gas
station that's as good as it gets dog
and they put you in the downstairs room
when i tell you it's [ __ ] freezing
it's [ __ ] freezing they got one diner
in the lobby and it's the worst food
you've ever eaten in your life even if
they give you the 30 off you rather
[ __ ] starve to death
that's how bad that place is and you're
stuck up there for two [ __ ] nights
next to a gas station
that's it i worked up there with tony v
do you know tony v [ __ ] yeah i worked up
there with tony v i was the middle he
was the headliner and some lady kept
flashing the light while i was on stage
i was supposed to do like i don't know
20 25 minutes something like that like
10 or 15 she's flashed online
uh and i did i ignored it i just did my
set i got off stage and she goes okay i
don't know if you know how we do it here
but you can't do that language of this
club and i remember saying like what are
you talking about i was i was smiling
laughing so i was already moved in new
york i was already like i was already
getting work i already had sussman as a
manager i was like what
and she was like you're going to have to
change your act to work oh no i'm not i
go what are you the manager here i go i
got booked here i got booked here by the
owner of the club i'm going to do my act
they know what my act is
you don't like it so you want me to
change
and like she looked at me and you know
like she didn't expect that
and i just raised my eyebrows and i just
walked away and i just finished out the
weekend and she never spoke a [ __ ]
word to me again she didn't say hi she
didn't look at me ain't that great when
you have the [ __ ] once uh yeah once
you want somebody to drop a bomb on a
[ __ ] and she'll just look at you
like what she was talking to me like she
was the manager at wendy's and i was the
fry boy
she's like i don't know if you know how
this works here you know like she's like
the lady that takes the tickets you know
those the clubs are all in a hotel you
know like bananas was in a hotel right
yeah both of them both of them so she
just decided she didn't like my act you
know because i talked about sex so she's
just decided that i was gonna have to
change my act i don't know i'll just
i'll never forget her face i don't know
if you know how we do it here but you
you can't do with that language here oh
[ __ ] you the race the word is a
jacqueline would [ __ ] everything that
moves female or male male oh no female
you know when i was a kid i remember
waking up and that [ __ ] had an
exercise show at 9am with the suit oh
yeah he had the suit so you never know i
didn't jumpsuit the [ __ ] jumpsuit no
no he would uh you know
he would uh
he was eating healthy before everybody
he was working out like deep into his
60s and 70s he was doing stunts more
like for his 60th birthday he towed like
60 boats behind him like swimming he
does he did a bunch of really crazy [ __ ]
like that like he was an incredible
fitness
incredible shape
he had [ __ ] everything you couldn't go
near him even when he was older
he was all there
i mean which makes sense
why would he be so motivated to have
such a great body like deep into his 50s
and 60s
you know your [ __ ] horny is this [ __ ]
yeah
when you throw a metal around and [ __ ]
and push-ups and pull-ups
you got dick for three or four people
you really do you really do well how
long have a plane ride would be from
miami like 20 minutes like how long
could it possibly be 40 minutes or
something it's not even 90 miles so it's
from here to san diego yeah that's like
not even half the trip to vegas they
have to do a circle just to feel good
just to make it worth it you know listen
man i don't know if before before 911
the trip to vegas was 40 minutes after 9
11 awesome it became an hour 10 plus
they doubled the price
so
those fees
these times the plane in vegas has been
50 minutes behind
and they still got me here on time
you know really right from
vegas to burbank they know it's not that
[ __ ] do you think you really think
they did take a securities route
really
why would they do that because how
guilty would you feel if you took
somebody for a half hour from here to
vegas it's not a guilt sizing 234
[ __ ] now the fuel the fuel cost so
much money they'd be crazy to do that i
don't know
[Music]
ain't the right way just the wrong way
[Music]